[संगीत]
ब
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग एक बार आप लोग ये
बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है या
नहीं आ रही चैट में बता दीजिए जल्दी से यस
या
नो
एक मिनट का वेट करते हैं जवाइन करने का
उसके बाद स्टार्ट करते
हैं
ब
चलो फिर किसी का वेट नहीं करते क्लास को
कंटिन्यू करते हैं टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करेंगे तो वेलकम टू डे सेन ऑफ दिस बेस्ट
कटिंग क्लास तो लास्ट क्लास में मैंने कुछ
वेरिएबल के बारे में बताया था और टाइप्स
ऑफ वेरिएबल के बारे में बताया था और थोड़ा
सा बताया था कि पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन होता
क्या है किस चीज को हम पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन
बोलते हैं आई होप सबको क्लियर होगा अगर
किसी को स्टिल कोई डाउट है तो ग्रुप में
पूछ सकता है अरवाज चैट में भी पूछ सकता है
या कमेंट करके पूछ सकता है तो हम उसको बता
देंगे तो अगर आप लोगों को याद हो कुछ टाइम
पहले मैंने एक क्वेश्चन आपको फाइंड आउट
करने के लिए बोला था कि आप लोगों के दिमाग
में एक सवाल आना चाहिए अगर नहीं आया तो
फिर आपको कोशिश करनी है कि क्या सवाल हो
सकता है च आज उसकी बारी मैं बता देता हूं
सवाल क्या हो सकता है फॉर एग्जांपल आपने
किसी भी स्क्रिप्ट को लिखा किसी भी
स्क्रिप्ट को डिजाइन किया और उसके बाद आप
स्क्रिप्ट को रन करना चाहते हैं अब ठीक है
आपने किसी भी पर्टिकुलर फोल्डर के अंदर
किसी पर्टिकुलर डायरेक्टरी के अंदर उस
स्क्रिप्ट को क्या
किया प्रोग्राम किया राइट किया तो अगला
सवाल यह उठता है कि मुझे क्या उस
स्क्रिप्ट को रन करने के लिए बारबार उसी
फोल्डर में जाना पड़ेगा क्या मैं अपने
स्क्रिप्ट को बाकी और टूल्स की तरह य नहीं
कर सकता जैसे कि मैंने कोई भी टूल इंस्टॉल
किया या कोई भी कमांड मैंने रन किया मैं
कहीं से भी उस कमांड को रन कर पाता हूं
मेरी मशीन के अंदर क्या मैं ऐसा नहीं कर
सकता सवाल उठता है यही यह सवाल आप लोग
दिमाग में आना चाहिए स्क्रिप्ट को क्या हम
कहीं से भी रन नहीं कर सकता क्या मुझे हर
बार वो फुल पाथ या फुल एब्सलूट पाथ मेंशन
करना पड़ेगा मुझे स्क्रिप्ट को रन करने के
लिए हर बार जब स्क्रिप्ट को रन करना
पड़ेगा ये सवाल आप लोग दिमाग में आना
चाहिए नहीं आना चाहिए था तो उसका जवाब है
उसका सलूशन है तो आज वही चीज मैं आपको
बताने वाला हूं कि क्या सलूशन है तो लास्ट
क्लास में जो हमने क्लास स्टॉप की थी जो
हमारा टाइम हो गया था उसम मैं कुछ बता रहा
था कुछ एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल थे कुछ कॉमन
वेरिएबल थे जो आपको पता होना चाहिए जैसे
कि डॉलर होम था डॉलर यूजर था डॉलर होस्ट
नेम था पोस्ट टाइप था सेल था पी डब्लू था
डब् ये
सारे के सारे क्या
है आपके कुछ वेरिएबल थे जो मैंने आपको
बताया था तो फिर कंटिन्यू करते हैं कुछ
वेरिएबल जिनके बारे में पढ़ने वाले तो
आपका जो सवाल है उसका जवाब आज इसी में
छुपा हुआ है कि क्या कहीं पर भी किसी भी
स्क्रिप्ट कर में कैसे कर सकता हूं तो एक
और एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल है एक और सिस्टम
डिफाइंड वेरिएबल है जिसके बारे में आपको
मैं बताने वाला
हूं जस्ट ब मैं जूम इन कर देता हूं आप
लोगों के
लिए चलो तो मैं क्या करता हूं एकको करता
हूं और
डॉलर पी एटी एच पाथ के बारे में मैं यह
करता और ट एंटर कर
दिया य पर बहुत कुछ पा दिखा यूजर लोकल एस
बिन यूजर एस बिनस नर्मल एस बिन यूजर लोकल
बिन यूजर बिन बिन नॉर्मल यूजर लोकल गेम्स
यूजर गेम्स काली डट नेट टूल्स यह बहुत कुछ
दिखा दे एक्चुअल में है क्या देखो क्या
होता है जब भी आप कोई भी कमांड एग्जीक्यूट
कराते हैं अपने टर्मिनल के ऊपर डायरेक्टली
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाती है जैसे कि एलएस कमांड
है पीडब्ल्यूडी कमांड है कैट कमांड है लेस
कमांड है तो यह कमांड डायरेक्टली
एग्जीक्यूट हो कैसे रही है सिस्टम को कैसे
पता चला कि इस कमांड की बाइनरी फाइल कहां
पर लोपिड है अगर मुझे पता करना हो जो मेरी
एलएस कमांड है या अदर कोई भी कमांड है
पीडब्ल्यूडी है कैट कमांड अगर उसकी बाइनरी
फाइल के बारे में मुझे पता करना हो तो मैं
कर सकता हूं सिंपली मैं क्या करूंगा विच
कमांड का यूज
करूंगा डब् एच आई सीच विच कमांड यज कर
कमांड का नाम लिख द सिंपली इसने बता दिया
इसको एला किया हुआ है कोई बात नहीं च
कमांड कि अरवाज मैंने कैट किया उसके बाद
यह रहा अब कैट कहां पर कमांड हमारी मशीन
में लोकेटेड है स्ल य स्ल बन कैट के अंदर
है तो अब यह चीज हमने पता करनी थी तो हमने
तो कमांड फायर कर ली लेकिन अब सिस्टम को
कैसे पता चला कि जो एलस कमांड है या कैट
कमांड है जो भी कमांड है उसकी बाइनरी फाइल
मुझे कहां से एग्जीक्यूट करवानी है तो यह
सिस्टम इस पाथ वेरिएबल की हेल्प से करता
है जो पाथ वेरिएबल है ना इसकी हेल्प से
करता है कैसे देखो इसी वेरिएबल की हेल्प
से सिस्टम जानता है कि सुपर यूजर की
बाइनरी फाइल की लोकेशन कहां पर है नॉर्मल
यूजर के बाइनरी फाइल की लोकेशन कहां पर है
अगर इन दोनों में अगर वह फाइल नहीं मिलती
तो क्या करता है कि वह फदर जितने भी यहां
पर मेंशन किए फॉर एग्जांपल ये रहा यूजर्स
की बाइनरी फाइल एस बन है है ये एस बिन है
फिर सिस्टम इसके बाद रूट यूजर्स की सुपर
यूजर्स की सारी यहां पर पाथ मेंशन किए हुए
हैं उसके अलावा एक्स्ट्रा पाथ भी मेंशन कि
फॉर एग्जांपल इनमें इसमें नहीं मिला तो
अगले वाले में जाएगा जहां पर ये सेमीकलन
सेपरेटेड फिर इसमें फिर इसमें सब में चेक
करेगा और जहां पर भी वो बाइनरी फाइल आपको
मिलेगी यह आपको क्या कर देगा एग्जीक्यूट
करवा देगा अगर हमने यहां पर उस कमांड की
बाइनरी फाइल को हटा दिया या उस कमांड की
बाइनरी फाइल इन लोकेशंस के अंदर नहीं है
तो क्या करना होगा उस कमांड को मुझे रन
करने के लिए फुल पाथ उस कमांड का मेंशन
करना पड़ेगा तभी उस कमांड को या उस बाइनरी
फाइल को मैं एग्जीक्यूट करवा पाऊंगा कैसे
की जैसे मुझे कैट कमांड को यूज करना तो
इसको फुल पाथ भी मैं यूज कर सकता हूं
मैंने ओके किया देन कैट किया एक मिनट अरे
रुको
यार मैं जैसे कि कोई कुछ भी करना है एल
करता मशीन में कोई फाइल
हैट में कर नहीं सकता मुझे अभी है नहीं तो
ये क्या है इसके बाइनरी फाइल इसका फुल पाथ
मुझे मेंशन करना है और उसके बाद क्या हो
किसी भी फाइल का नाम मैं इसके अंदर सामने
शो करूंगा तो उसकी क्या है कंटेंट को ये
आपके आउटपुट में शो करेगा तो आपको पता चल
गया कि पाथ वेरिएबल का क्या रोल आपकी मशीन
में और अगर मुझे अपनी स्क्रिप्ट जो भी
स्क्रिप्ट में डिजाइन कर रहा हूं मैं
चाहता हूं कि मैं अपनी उस स्क्रिप्ट को एक
नाम से सिंगल उसके नाम से मैं कहीं से भी
उसको एग्जीक्यूट कर पाऊं तो उसकी बाइनरी
फाइल्स की एंट्री इन फाइल्स के अंदर होनी
चाहिए मतलब कि वो बाइनरी फाइल्स इनके अंदर
होनी ही चाहिए किसी भी पात में या
उसका पाथ मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा इस पाथ
वेरिएबल के अंदर डिफाइन करना होगा अगर
मुझे इसके अंदर वो डिफाइन नहीं की बाइनरी
फाइल तो मुझे हर बार उसका फुल पाथ मेंशन
करके उस स्क्रिप्ट को उस बैनरी फाइल को या
उस कमांड को रन करना होगा तो यह पाथ
वेरिएबल की पावर थी और यही जो आपका जो
डाउट था जो आपके दिमाग में आना चाहिए था
उसका जवाब यहीं पर यह
है अब बात करते हैं एक और मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट वेरिएबल होता है जिसको हम
बोलते हैं पी एस वन वेरिएबल
पीएस व वेरिएबल कौन सा होता है मैं एक बार
स्क्रीन क्लियर कर देता हूं आपके सामने
पीएस व वेरिएबल ये होता है मैं ब कमेंट
दिखाता हूं आपको यह होता है पी एस व
वेरिएबल ये पीव
वेरिएबल जो पीएस व वेरिएबल है वो यह
डिटरमाइंड करता है कि जो हमारा सेल है वो
प्रोमट सेल प्रोमट कौन सा है हमने देखा है
कि जब भी हम बेस सेल यूज करते हैं तो
प्रोमट कुछ इस तरह का दिखता है मतलब की ज
सेल यूज कि तो प्रम इस तरह का दिखेगा
बेस्ट सेल यूज करेंगे तो किसी तरीके प्रम
दिखेगा प्रोमट होता क्या है जो मैं आपको
एक बार एग्जांपल तौर पर दिखाता हूं ये रहा
बहुत सारे प्रोमट होते हैं आपको ऐसे भी
देखने को मिलते है कई बार प्रम फर स्कल
डाउन करता हूं ये रहा एक प्रम इस तरह का
आपको देखने को मिलता है ये रहा अगर आपको
मैं बैक बैक बैक बैक बैक ये रहा इस तरह का
प्रोमट देखने को मिल रहा है य डॉक्यूमेंट
डोटल उसके बाद ऐसे कलर्स एक य प्रोमट हो
सकता है दूसरा कैसा प्रोमट हो सकता है इस
तरीके से यह सारे क्या है यह सारे प्रोमट
है उसके बाद आप ये हो गया उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट प्रोमट आपको देखने को मिला होगा
ये रहा इस टाइप से भी आपका प्रंट है नाम
उसके बाद डेट टाइम उसका बाद डैश डैश डैश
ये फिर ये तो ये ये सारे प्रोमट है तो ये
जो प्रोमट है कैसे डिटरमाइंड किए जाते हैं
किसके अंदर डिफाइन किए जाते हैं वो और ये
किसके हिसाब से सेट होते है सारी चीजें
आपके इस पीएस व जो वेरिएबल है ये रहा पीएस
व वेरिएबल है इसके अंदर डिटरमाइंड किया
जाता है इसके अंदर डिफाइन किया जाता है कि
आपका जो प्रोमट है आपको स्क्रीन पर देखने
को मिल रहा है वो
कैसा है वो किस तरह का दिखेगा किस तरीके
से होता है फर एपल इसकी अगर वैल्यू को
देखना चाहते हो तो उसको भी देख सकते हैं
एकको करता हूं और डॉलर पी एस व करता हूं
पस डॉलर नहीं ओके डॉलर करना मुझे यूज कर
लिया मैंने पव अब देखो इसम बहुत कुछ दिखाई
दे रहा है क्योंकि यह इसके हिसाब से है य
जो कुछ आपको दिखाई दे रहा है यह ज के
हिसाब से दिखाई दे रहा है हर एक कपड़ मतलब
ज आपको काली भी दिख रहा होगा यह के दिखे फ
काली फिर यह ब्रैकेट कैसे आएगा डैश फिर यह
यहां पर नॉर्मल यूजर होगा या रूट यूजर य
चेंज नहीं यहां पर य फंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टरी उसके बाद यह रहा डॉलर सिंबल या
नॉर्मल यूजर होगा कौन सा यूजर उसके बाद
कमांड फायर होती है इस तरीके का जो प्रंट
है सारा इधर इसमें डिफाइंड है सब कुछ कलर
कैसा होगा ब्लू ग्रीन जहां कैसा कलर होगा
यह सब कुछ इसके अंदर डिफाइंड है तो इस
तरीके से और यह क्या है कि सेल टू सेल
डिपेंड करता है हर एक सेल का अलग-अलग हो
सकता है फॉर एग्जांपल मैं अगर बैस करता
हूं अब मैं इसका
एकको डॉलर सेल करता हूं तो जड एसएससी सेल
अभी बैस में कन्वर्ट नहीं हुआ तो अभी
देखो अगर इसको मुझे क्या करना है अगर मुझे
इसको चेंज करना है तो अभी मैं इसको चेंज
कर सकता हूं मतलब मैं क्या कर सकता हूं
इसको चेंज कर सकता हूं कैसे चेंज कर सकता
हूं सिंपली अब मैं टेंपररी करके दिखा रहा
हूं अगर आपको परमानेंट चेंज करना है
परमानेंट चेंज करने के लिए आपको क्या करना
पड़ेगा इसकी जो एंट्री डॉट बस आरसी एक
फाइल होती है प्रोफाइल फाइल होती है उसके
अंदर करनी पड़ेगी अगर उसको परमानेंटली सेट
करना है बट मैं अभी आपको टप दिखाता फॉर
एग्जांपल पी एव और मैं इक्वल साइन कर देता
हूं और मैं चाहता हूं कि जो आपको दिखाई दे
मैं लिख रहा हूं यहां
पर डीई एफ आर ओ एन आई डे फोनिक्स एस एच एल
सेल ऐसा मिले बस और आपको ऐसे देखने को
मिले यह रहा स्पेस ऐसे आपको सेल देखने को
मिले तो जैसे ही मैंने हिट एंडर किया अभी
देखो डेनिक सेल इसम मैं कोई भी कमांड फ
करूंगा इफ
कॉन्फिनेट आ गया उसके बाद क्या है कि अगर
एकको करता हूं मैं और उसके बाद मैं आपको
डॉलर पी एव वेरिएबल आपको शो करता हूं तो
अभी क्या है मैंने इसमें क्या इसके अंदर
जो पीएस वेरिएबल की जो वैल्यू है वो आपको
क्या दिखाई दे रही है डे फोनिक सेल आपको य
इस तरह का देखने को मिल रहा है उससे पहले
जो वैल्यू आपको देखने को मिल रही थी वो
किस तरीके से देखने को मिल रही थी तो इस
तरीके से हमने क्या कर दिया अभी इसका जो
प्रोमट था उस प्रोमट को हमने चेंज कर दिया
बट ये टेंपरेरी किया परमानेंट सेट नहीं
किया था इस तरीके इसका मतलब ये है कि जो
सेल जो हम यूज कर रहे हैं उसका एनवायरमेंट
किस तरह का रहेगा किस तरह से वो दिखाई
देगा ये सब सेट होता है आपका पीएस व
वेरिएबल के हिसाब से और ये पीएस व वेरिएबल
ही इस चीज को डिफाइन करता है ओके और आप अब
मैं एक और चीज बताता हूं जितने भी जो
सिस्टम डिफाइंड वेरिएबल है जो एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल है उनको क्या है आप तीन तरीके से
सेट कर सकते हो टेंपरेरी भी सेट कर सकते
हो परमानेंट भी सेट कर सकते हो ग्लोबली भी
सेट कर सकते हो ये मैं आप मैं अपनी कास की
सीरीज में आपको पहले बता चुका हूं प्लीज
जाइए उधर अगर जिसको नहीं पता व उधर से वो
जाके सीख सकता है अभी जैसे कि टेंपररी
टेंपररी कैसे सेट कर सकते हैं आपको पता है
टेंपररी भी बताया अगर परमानेंट सेट करना
तो उसको एक्सपोर्ट करना होगा मुझे ग्लोबली
सेट करना हो तो मुझे क्या करना पड़ा जो
प्रोफाइल फाइल होती है जो आपकी ग्लोबल
प्रोफाइल फाइल है उसके अंदर उसको मुझे
एक्सपोर्ट करना स्ल टीसी के अंदर जो
प्रोफाइल फइल थ उसके अंदर अगर मैं इसको
एक्सपोर्ट करूंगा तो वो क्या है
परमानेंटली ग्लोबली परमानेंटली सेट हो
जाएंगी इस तरीके से आप किसी भी वेरिएबल को
सेट कर सकते हो परमानेंट टेंपररी और
ग्लोबली ये जस्ट इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए तो एक
बार मैं इसको लॉग आउट करके लॉग इन करता
हूं वापस
से
ओके क्लियर अभी आपको ऐसे दिख अभी तक मैंने
क्या बताया जो वेरिएबल क्या होते हैं कुछ
यूजर डिफाइंड वेरिएबल कैसे क्रिएट कर सकते
हो उसके कुछ रूल्स है सिस्टम डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल कुछ जो इंपोर्टेंट वेरिएबल थे वो
जो आपको देखने को मिल रहे हैं वो आपको पता
चल गया होगा अब मैं आपको सिखाता हूं कि जो
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है वो होता क्या है
मैं जो बताता हूं पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन मैं
आपकी बात करता हूं मैं ये रहा पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन की बात करता हूं
आज ये रहा पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन होता क्या है इसके
बारे में बात करने वाले हैं कोई इसमें कोई
थरेट कल नहीं है पूरा पूरा प्रैक्टिकल से
आपका जो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है कुछ भी
थियोरेटिकल नहीं है इसमें तो पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन के बारे में सीखते हैं तो चलते
हैं चलो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन पे अभी आप
लोगों को पता है कि वेरिएबल कैसे डिफाइन
करना है सबको पता है तो अगर वेरिएबल कैसे
डिफाइन करता है फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने
वेरिएबल का नाम लिखा की नेम नेम लिखा देन
इक्वल साइन लिखा उसके बाद मैंने क्या लिखा
ए कैपिटल आईटी कैपिटल ई फिर एस और एच ते
ऐसे कर दिया एक वेरिएबल मैंने डिफाइन कर
दिया अब अगर मुझे इसकी वैल्यू को फैच करना
हो इसकी वेरिएबल को रेफरेंस लेना हो अगर
इसकी वेरिएबल को मुझे क्या करना एकको करना
हो या प्रिंट करना हो तो मैं कैसे करूंगा
एकको किया और सिंपली आपको पता है डॉलर मैं
क्या लिख दूं डॉलर
नेम नेम लिख दिया हिट एंटर इसकी वैल्यू आ
गई नितेश अभी एक तो ये तरीका आपको पता है
दूसरा जो सबसे बेस्ट तरीका है जो एक बोलते
हैं कि सबसे सही तरीका है एक प्रोफेशनल
तरीका है वो क्या है आपको पता है कि आप
कर्ली बेसस यूज करके इसको यूज कर सकते हैं
ऐसे आप यूज अब कैसे कर सकते हो कर्ली
ब्रेसस के अंदर ऐसे ये रहा कर्ली ब्रेसस
और ये रहा टटर ये भी वैल्यू सेम आएगी ये
सबसे सही परफेक्ट तरीका है यही इसका एक
प्रोफेशनल तरीका है मतलब जो सिंटेक्स
बोलते हैं परफेक्ट सिंटेक्स ही है अब अगर
आप ऐसे यूज करते हो तो आप पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंस के जो एडवांस फीचर्स है जो मैं
आपको अभी बताने वाला हूं वो आप यूज नहीं
कर पाओगे लेकिन अगर मैं ऐसे यूज करता हूं
तो आप क्या कर पाओगे जो पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन जो एडवांस फीचर्स है आप वो यूज
कर पाएंगे और इसी के अंदर ही वो काम करते
हैं कर्ली ब्रेसस के ही अंदर वो काम करते
हैं जो एडवांस फीचर जिसकी अब हम बात करने
वाले हैं ले तो वो कौन-कौन से जस्ट अ मिनट
होल्ड ऑन गाइ समवन ऑन माय
गेट
सॉरी फॉर डिस्टरबेंस चलो बात करते हैं
कंटिन्यू फॉर एजाम पल मुझे क्या करना है
कि जो मेरा यह वेरिएबल है वेरिएबल में जो
भी वैल्यू है तो मैं क्या चाहता हूं कि यह
वेरिएबल है जो फर्स्ट लेटर है वो लोअर केस
हो मैं क चाहता हूं कि जो फर्स्ट वेरिएबल
जो फर्स्ट लेटर है कैरेक्टर है इसका क्या
है व वैल्यू लोअर केस आ तो कैसे करूंगा
मैं एकको करूंगा उसके बाद डॉलर करूंगा
उसके बाद मैं कली ब्रेसस और कली ब्रेसस के
अंदर मैं नेम वेरिएबल लिखूंगा देन मुझे
यूज करना है इसके बाद कमा सिंपली मैं यूज
करूंगा कमा और ट एटर कर
दीजिए
ट बैड सब्सीट्यूशन
ओके जस बैड
सब्सीट्यूशन इसमें चेंज नहीं होके मैं
क्या काम करता हूं एक स्क्रिप्ट कट कर
लेता हू नो किया मैंने और मैं क्या करता
हूं
बेस स्क्रिप्ट डॉट
एस ओके आपको पता है सबसे पहले क्या स लाइन
ड करनी है स
सिंपल लाइन स्ल बन स् बस ओके नेक्स्ट लाइन
अब मैं क्या करता हूं क्या करता मैंने एक
वेबल डिफाइन किया नेम वेबल का नाम लिखा
मैंने ए आईटी कैपिटल ई और एस एच नितेश
नेक्स्ट मुझे क्या करना है अगर एकको करना
है मैं एकको करता हूं उसके बाद मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं डॉलर करली ब्रेसस और मैं चाहता
हूं फर्स्ट कैरेक्टर जो मेरा है वो क्या
आए लोअर केस आ फर्स्ट कैरेक्टर ओनली
फर्स्ट कैरेक्टर ट एंटर किया कंट्रोल एक्स
करता हूं और मैं इसको
यस यस अब मु उसको मुझे एग्जीक्यूट करवाना
हो तो मैं क्या करूंगा
बेस ओके सीच
मोड 744 नेक्स्ट
बस
एस दिख रहा होगा अब मैं क्या करता
हूं टर अभी आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा जो
फर्स्ट कैरेक्टर है य फर्स्ट जो कक्टर है
क्या दिख रहा आपको ए आपको क्या दिख रहा है
अब लो कैस में दिखाई दे रहा है अभी एक चीज
ध्यान में रखना की जो भी य वैल्यू चेंज
हुई आपकी जो भी वैल्यू उसने चेंज करके
दिखाई वो क्या है आपका आपकी जो ओरिजिनल जो
वेरिएबल था उसके अंदर चेंज नहीं हु जस्ट इ
रिप्रेजेंटेशन चेंज किया अगर मैं ओरिजिनल
वैल्यू देखूंगा को रिजनल वैलू र नहीं देख
आपको नल वल्य देखने के लिए हम इस ननो करते
हैं इसके बाद यहा अब इसकी अगर ओरिजनल
वैल्यू देखूंगा फर एपल अभी इसके बाद मैंने
क्या इसम रिशन चेंज किया मैं क्या करता
हूं को को और मैं क्या करता हूं
अभी
य
ओरिजनल वैल्यू
जो होगी मैं क्या करता हूं डॉलर लिब उसके
अंदर मैं क्या करता हूं नेम करता हूं य
आपको देखने को मिलेगी ओरिजनल वैल्यू य
इसमें कोई भी चेंज नहीं होगा आपको जब भी
मैं स्क्रिप्ट को रन करूंगा तो आपको देखने
को मिलेगी अब मैं फॉर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या
चाहता हूं कि
जो जो भी जो क्या है कि इसके सारे के सारे
कक्टर हम लोवर केस करना चाहता हूं सारे के
सारे कक्टर जो ये है इसके सारे के सारे जो
कैरेक्टर्स को लोवर केस करना चाहता उसके
लिए मैं क्या करूंगा को उसके उसके बाद
डॉलर यूज करूंगा ने उसके बाद कली बेसस
उसके बाद मैं नेम के बाद मैं यूज करूंगा
डबल डबल को ये कॉमा यूज करूंगा तो इससे
क्या होगा सारे के सारे कैरेक्टर्स क्या
होंगे लोअर केस हो जाएंगे फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं कंट्रोल एक्स करके दिखाता हूं कंट्रोल
एक्स नेक्स्ट यस अब उसके बाद इसको
स्क्रिप्ट को रन करर देखो पहले लो इसके
बाद ओरिजनल ये रहा अब सारे के स सारे
कैरेक्टर्स क्या हो गए लोअर केस हो गए अब
मैं क्या मैं क्या चाहता हूं मैं
कि ये रहा एच अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं कि
ओनली फर्स्ट कैरेक्टर है जो ओनली फर्स्ट
कैरेक्टर है वो ऑलरेडी क्या है कैपिटल है
तो मैं एक और एक काम कर देता हूं कि इसकी
अबकी बार मैं क्या कर देता हूं इसको हटा
देता हूं सबको हटा देता हूं रिजनल वैल्यू
चेंज होनी नहीं
सिंपली एक बार अब मैंने क्या कर दिया एस ए
सी एच आ स चन किया उसके बाद नेक्स्ट किया
अब मैं क्या करता हूं एकको एकको और ओनली
फर्स्ट क्याट एकको डॉलर देन करली ब्रेसस
उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं नेम देन अगर
मुझे ओनली फर्स्ट कैरेक्टर को कैपिटल करना
है तो मैं यूज करूंगा यह वाला सिंबल ये अप
एरो यूज करूंगा देन ये ओनली फर्स्ट
कैरेक्टर को क्या
करेगा मैं इसके कमेंट कर देता हूं उसके
सामने शो डट
की इट ू
ओनली
ओनली फर्स्ट कैरेक्टर
कैपिटल कैपिटल ओके अगर मैं क्या चाहता हूं
कि सारे के सारे कैरेक्टर कैपिटल करना
चाहता हूं एक को करूंगा उसके बाद डॉलर
करूंगा पली बस उसके बाद में नेम देन य डबल
यह वाला सिंबल डबल यूज करोगे तो य क्या
करेगा
ऑल कैरेक्टर्स इन
कैपिटल कैपिटल कर देगा यह सारे
सारे कैपिटल एक और फीचर होता है इसका अगर
आप यह चेक करना चाहता हो चाहते हो कि जैसे
कि य नेम है इसके अंदर कितने इसकी जो लेंथ
है लेंथ चेक करना चाहते हो कैसे चेक करोगे
व आपको बताता उसकी लेंथ चेक करने के
लिए इसमें फीचर होता है डॉलर कली बेसस
उसके बाद क्या है नेम इसके अंदर ओके
डलर य और उसके बाद क्या करोगे आप इसके
अंदर आप मेंशन कर दोगे है सिंबल इसके
सामने क्या करोगे है सिंबल आप मेंशन कर
दोगे
ट एन ए
एम
न व
रेड ए
नेमस उसके बाद डलर सिल देखते इसके बाद काम
करर नहीं कंट्रोल एक्स करता
हूं एक्स यस अब स्क्रिप्ट को रन कर देते
हैं अभी देखो हां काम कर रहा है मैंने
क्या बोला था ओनली फर्स्ट लेटर मुझे
कैपिटल चाहिए तो एस कैपिटल कर दिया सभी के
सभी कैपिटल तो सभी के सभी अग उसकी लेंथ
देखना चाहता हूं उसके जो वेरिएबल में जो
जो भी वैल्यू स्टोर उसकी अगर लेंथ को मैं
देखना चाहता हूं उसके लिए भी आप यूज कर
सकते हो यह है सिंबल मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं य रहा य आप यूज करोगे स्टार्टिंग में
हैश सिंबल लगाओगे उसके बाद वेरिएबल का नाम
तो इसके अंदर ही ये सारे फीचर्स काम करते
हैं इसके अलावा कहीं पर भी ये फीचर्स काम
नहीं करते अगर डायरेक्टली विदाउट कली
ब्रेसस आप यूज करोगे तो वेरिएबल के साथ तो
ये फीचर्स कोई भी काम नहीं करते ओनली
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन के अंदर ही काम करते
हैं एक कांसेप्ट होता है स्लाइसिंग का
स्लाइसिंग का कांसेप्ट क्या होता है मैं
आपको समझा देता हूं ये जैसे स्लाइसिंग
क्या होता है जैसे फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने
कैरेक्टर लिया फॉर एग्जांपल ये है एक
कैरेक्टर कोई भी एक कक्टर लिखा मैंने लिखा
था इधर एस ए सी एच आई सचन तो क्या होता है
कि जब भी कोई भी एक स्ट्रिंग है स्ट्रिंग
बोल सकते हैं हम कोई भी वेरिएबल के अंदर
जो भी वैल्यू स्टोर होती है वो इंडेक्सिंग
होती है इंडेक्सिंग कैसे होती है कि जो एस
है जो एस होगा आपका यह रहा इसका जो अरे
यार ये
रहा आपको वैसे बता देता
हूं सचिन तो इसका जो फर्स्ट एस है इसकी
इंडेक्सिंग होती है इंडेक्सिंग में क्या
होता है जो ए है ये जीरो इंडेक्स पर है
एव सी2 इंडेक्स h3 आई
फ n 5 ऐसे इंडेक्सिंग होगी इसके इंडेक्स
क्या हो गया जीरो जो मैं आपको अगर इसमें
शो करता हूं इंडेक्सिंग होती है हर एक
कक्टर जितने भी जो वैल्यू स्टोर होती है
उसकी इंडेक्सिंग होती है इंडेक्सिंग
इंडेक्सिंग कैसे होती है
इंडेक्सिंग हर एक उसकी वैल्यू की
इंडेक्सिंग जो जीरो पर है जीरो इंडेक्स पर
क्या है आपका ए है उसके बाद वन इंडेक्स पर
आपका क्या है वो ए है उसके बाद टू इंडेक्स
प आपका क्या है सी है उसके बाद थ्री
इंडेक्स प आपका क्या है एच है नेक्स्ट
फोर्थ इंडेक्स प आपका क्या है आई है उसके
बाद फिफ्थ इंडेक्स प आपका क्या है वो आपका
ए है अब इंडेक्सिंग का आपको पता चल गया
लेकिन स्लाइसिंग क्या होता स्लाइसिंग क्या
होता है कि फॉर एग्जांपल कोई भी आपने एक
वर्ड लिखा हुआ
[संगीत]
है दिस
इज दिस इज दिस
इज इन सर क्लास ओके स क्लास ये मैंने लिखा
अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं कि इस पर्टिकुलर जो
य लिखा लाइन में मैं क्या पिक किसी एक
सेक्शन को क्रॉप करना चाहता हूं किसी
पर्टिकुलर सेक्शन को ही देखना चाहता हूं
या तो मैं इ सचिन देखना चाहता हूं या सचिन
सर देखना चाहता हूं या ओनली क्लास देखना
चाहता हूं किसी पर्टिकुलर सेक्शन को मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं इसमें ओनली
रिप्रेजेंट करना चाहता हूं तो उसके लिए हम
यूज करते हैं स्लाइसिंग उसके लिए हम क्या
यूज करते हैं स्लाइसिंग करते हैं
स्लाइसिंग क्या करते हैं
कि स्लाइसिंग के लिए मैं लिखता हूं यह
रहा स्लाइसिंग इसको बोलते हम स्लाइसिंग
अदर प्रोग्राम लैंग्वेज में भी इसका यूज
किया जा स्लाइसिंग क्या होता है इट
इनेबल्स
इनेबल्स अस टू
टेक जस्ट ए स्मॉल
सेक्शन स्मल सेक्शन अब सिंटेक्स क्या होता
है सिंटेक्स मैं आपको बताऊ अगर सेक्शन
सेक्शन अब मैं सिंटेक्स की बात करता हूं
सिंटेक्स इसका कैसा होता है फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं डॉलर कली ब्रेसस यूज करूंगा डॉलर कली
ब्रेसस है सबसे पहले हम लिखते हैं टर का
नाम पैरामीटर या वेरिएबल का नाम उसके बाद
हम मेंशन करते हैं कॉलन कॉलन के बाद हम
मेंशन करते ऑफसेट ऑफसेट मुझे क्या है मुझे
इसको स्टार्ट कहां से करना है उसके बाद
लेंथ एल ई एन जी टी एस लेंथ उसके बाद क्या
करता हूं मैं लेंथ ये होता सबसे पहले
पैरामीटर फिर ऑफसेट फिर लेंथ ये इसका
सिंटेक्स ये इसका क्या है सिंटेक्स अ
किसको इसका स्क्रीनशॉट लेना है इसको
हाईलाइट करना है व्ट एवर आप इसको कर सकते
हो ये है सिंटेक्सिस का डॉलर क सबसे पहले
पैरामीटर का नाम होगा या वेरिएबल का नाम
होगा उसके बाद ऑफसेट सेट करोगे कि मुझे
कहां से स्टार्ट करना है जैसे कि मुझे
स्टार्ट करना है एच से तो इसका ऑफसेट क्या
रहेगा वन है पहला जीरो होगा उसके बाद मुझे
लेंथ कितने तक नट 3 फर 5 6 7 8 ना 10 ऐसे
कितने तक मुझे इसकी लेंथ चाहिए तो सब आप
क्या है इसके अंदर देख सकते हो स्पेस भी
यहां पर एक इंडेक्स के रूप में काउंट होता
है तो इसको हम कैसे यूज करेंगे अपनी
स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर मैं आपको दिखाता हूं
फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मैं क्या करता हूं आपके
सामने इस सभी को मैं डिलीट कर कर देता हूं
अभी सबको मैं डिलीट कर देता हूं यहां
लिखता
हूं दिस इज
बेस मास्टर क्लास ओके दिस इज बेस मास्टर
क्लास किया उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
एकको करता हूं और मैं ये देखना चाहता हूं
मैं स्लाइसिंग अब यूज करता हूं स्लाइसिंग
कैसे यूज करते ह मैं आपको सिखाता हूं सबसे
पहले पैरामीटर का नाम पैरामीटर का नाम
क्या लिखा मैंने नेम लिखा नेक्स्ट उसके
बाद मैं ऑफसेट क्या जाता हूं मैंने लिखा
रेंडम ता हूं मैं जाता हूं सेकंड ऑफसेट
सेकंड ऑफसेट से कितनी लेंथ चाहिए मुझे
मुझे लेंथ चाहिए से मुझे से लेंथ चाहिए
इट्स ओके अब मैं क्या कंट्रोल एस कर देता
हूं कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स उसके बाद यह
देखो अब मैं इसको रन करता हूं यह देखो
कमांड नोट फाउंड लाइन टू कमा न ओके
ट ओके हा इसको हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा जब
कंटिन्यू है स् सेपरे होगी तो हम इसस इसके
अंदर लेना पड़ेगा डबल कोट के अंदर ने नाउ
इट्स वर्किंग
फाइन अब अब बात कर चलो य रहा इज इज बी
कैसे आया इ इज बी कैसे आया मैं आपको शो
करता हूं इ इ बी कैसे आया अभी आप देखो ये
चलते है इज इज बी देखो सेकंड है जीवट
सेकंड य रहा ये
रहा तो एक दो दो तीन चार पा छ सात
इंक्लूडिंग है सात तक है य भी होता अब मैं
क्या चाता हूं ओनली बेस प्रिंट करना चाहता
बेस्ट ये वाला देखना चाहता तो इसके लिए
मुझे
जीवट टूथ फर फ स से 8 से स्टार्ट करना ए
से कितना फोर कक्टर ये भी हम कर सकते हैं
कैसे करेंगे ये रहा मुझे स्टार्ट करना ए
से उसके बाद मैं चाता हूं फोर कक्टर ये फो
और कंट्रोल एस एक्स अब मैं इसको रन करर
हूं य आपको देखने को मिलेगा बेस ओनली बैस
इसने इसके सामने आपको रिप्रेजेंट कर दिया
अब क्या है कि अगर आप क्या करते हो अगर
मैं आपको शो करता हूं अगर आप डायरेक्ट अरे
टोल ये रहा अगर आप क्या करते हो
डायरेक्टली सिंपली एकको किया आपने अगर
एकको कर दिया और डॉलर आपने क्या कर दिया
उसके बाद कली ब्रेसस उसके बाद आपने क्या
कर दिया नेम नेम लिखा फिर ऑफसेट में आपने
ओनली क्या कर दिया ऑफसेट में लिख दिया
आपने एट ओनली एट लिखा देन आपने इसको क्लोज
कर दिया ये क्या करेगा एट के बाद यहां पर
लेंथ मेंशन आपने नहीं की तो क्या करेगा
समझेगा ए के बाद मुझे ओनली ऑफसेट दिया कोई
लन नहीं मुझे सब का सब प्रिंट करना है अगर
आपने ऐसा किया अगर एक और तरीका अगर आपने
इस तरीके से किया आपने एग्जांपल नेम ऑफसेट
लिखा एट उसके बाद
फिर कॉलन दे दिया उसके बाद छोड़ दिया तो
ये क्या समझेगा कि आठ के बाद जीरो दिया आठ
के बाद आपने जीरो लेंथ पुट की है तो यह
आपको कुछ भी शो नहीं करेगा क्योंकि इसके
बाद जीरो मतलब कुछ भी प्रिंट नहीं करेगा
नेक्स्ट आप क्या कर सकते हो एक पहले इनका
आउटपुट आपको शो करके दिखाता हूं आपको यह
रहा बस पहले बैस आया था बेस मास्टर उसके
बाद एमटी लाइन इसलिए प्रिंट की क्योंकि
जीरो उसने इसको एमटी समझा जीरो समझा
क्योंकि यहां पर कुछ भी आपने दिया नहीं
ओनली जीरो समझा आप चाहो तो अब आप क्या कर
सकते हो आपका जोय होता है ना ये है जो
इंडेक्स है ये नेगेटिव इंडेक्सिंग भी आप
कर सकते हो नेगेटिव इंडेक्सिंग क्या चाहते
हो कि फॉर एग्जांपल मैं चाहता हूं कि यहां
से एल एल से लेके a s एस आ तो लास्ट में
कितनी लेंथ है चार है लेकिन मैं यहीं से
चाहता हूं इंडेक्सिंग तो वैसे तो अगर आगे
से देखोगे 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
ऐसे है अ लेकिन अगर नेगेटिव इंडेक्सिंग
देनी है तो आप नेगेटिव इंडेक्सिंग भी दे
सकते हैं लेकिन कैसे करोगे ये रहा -1 -2
-3 -4 मैं नेगेटिव इंडेक्स कैसे दूंगा ये
रहा
एकको
डॉलर उसके बाद नेम देन उसके बाद स्पेस
देना है माइनस इंडेक्सिंग में -4 देन उसके
बाद नेक्स्ट अब कोई स्पेस नहीं देना आप
जितनी लेन चाहते हो फोर उसके बाद मैं
कंट्रोल एक्स करता हूं कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल
एक्स करता हूं आपको देखना देखने को मिलेगा
ये रहा एल ए एसएस आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है उससे पहले ब्लैंक क्योंकि आपका ऑफसेट
जीरो उसने कंसीडर किया होगा तो अगर आप
यहां पर स्पेस नहीं देते तो क्या होगा
आपका बेस कंफ्यूज हो जाएगा
और उसको समझ में नहीं आए कि मुझे इसके साथ
करना क्या है और आपको कुछ रिजल्ट आपको जो
चाहते हो वसा आपको देखने को नहीं मिलेगा
अगर नेगेटिव इंडेक्सिंग आप यूज करना चाहते
वो भी यूज कर सकते नेगेटिव कैसे काउंट
करेगा जीरो यूज नहीं करता -1 -2 -3 -4 ऐसे
यूज करता -5 -6 कंटिन्यू ऐसे नेट
इंडेक्सिंग करता है उसके बाद लाइन दे सकते
हो तो इस तरीके से ये था आपका कांसेप्ट ऑफ
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन इस तरीके से आप क्या
कर सकते हो पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन को यूज कर सकते हो यह था आपका
पूरा कांसेप्ट ऑफ पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन का
जो नेक्स्ट कांसेप्ट है एक और है मैं आपको
बताता हूं कि मुझे एक बार चैट में बता
दीजिए जितने भी लोग यहां पर प्रेजेंट है
कि जो पैरामीटर एक्सपेंशन है आपका वो आपको
समझ में आया या नहीं आया यस या नो बता
दीजिए जितने भी प्रेजेंट
है
ब
इट्स ओके चलो फिर कोई बताने वाला नहीं है
तो हम क्या करते हैं नेक्स्ट एक और छोटा
सा कांसेप्ट जो आज मुझे डिलीवर करना है
आपको जो है आपका टिल डे एक्सपेंशन जिसकी
बात करने वाले हैं हम टिल डे
एक्सपेंशन ये रहा नेक्स्ट टॉपिक आज का एक
और है छोटा सा फ टू 10 मिनट का टिल डी
एक्सपेंशन
टिल डी
एक्सपेंशन टिल एक्सपेंशन के बारे में आज
हम पढ़ने वाले हैं क्योंकि यह भी आपका
पार्ट क्या है उसी का पार्ट आपका टिडी
एक्सपेंशन तो टिल एक्सपेंशन है इसको मैं
कलर हाईलाइट कर देता हूं ये रहा नो नो नो
दिस इ रंग कलर ये रहा इट्स ओके ट
एक्सपेंशन के बारे में बताता हूं देखो
क्या होता है कि सबसे पहले हम इसमें
सीखेंगे पूरे पूरे कांसेप्ट में ट
एक्सपेंशन होता क्या है क्यों हम इसको यूज
करते हैं और कुछ उसके एडवांस फीचर्स के
बारे में ऑलरेडी नॉर्मली आप इसको यूज करते
हो लेकिन य टेक्निकल नाम सुनके आपको ऐसा
लग रहा होगा होता क्या है देखो क्या होता
है जो टल एक्सपेंशन है उसको वो परफॉर्म
किया जाता है एक स्पेशल कैरेक्टर की हेल्प
से एक स्पेशल कैरेक्टर की हेल्प
से स्पेशल
कैरेक्टर उस स्पेशल कक्टर कौन सा होता है
आपका जो देखने में कैसा होता है ये रहा ये
है आपका टिल डे सिंबल आपका टिल सिंबल यही
है वो स्पेशल कैरेक्टर जिसकी हम बात कर
रहे हैं टिल डे
सिंबल ये आपका टिल डे सिंबल अभी क्या करता
है य टिल सिंपल य क्या करता है इसके बारे
में लिखता हूं मैं
इट अलाउ अस टू
इजली इली रेफर्स टू टू
द करंट
यूजर्स
होम सीटीओ आर
डायरेक्टरी
विदाउट
हैविंग हैविंग टू
टाइप
आउट फुल पाथ अब टिड एक्सपेंशन क्या है
इसके अंदर क्या होता है इस कक्टर अंदर जो
वैल्यू स्टोर होती है आपके जो करंट यूजर्स
है उसकी होम की वैल्यू इसके अंदर स्टोर
होती है और जब भी हम इसको यूज करते हैं तो
उसकी वैल्यू को रेफर करने के लिए इसका हम
यूज करते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल मा अगर आपको
एग्जांपल के रूप में अगर मैं दिखाता हूं
अगर मैं एकको करता हूं और डल टिली सिंबल
यूज किया तो ये क्या
गया स्लश होम स्ल काली आपके सामने देखने
को मिल रहा है क्योंकि करंट यूजर जो यूजर
है वो काली है और उसका जो होम है उसका फुल
पाथ इसने मेंशन कर दिया अभी आपको क्या है
कि इससे फायदा क्या हुआ कि बारबार आपको
क्या है स्लश होम स्लश काली आपको क्या
करना है टाइप करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ रही
यह सारे काम क्या है हार्ड वर्क हैय टिल
डे सिंबल अपने आप खुद से ही कर देता है
आपको उसको रिमेंबर करने की जरूरत नहीं है
यह तो क्या है इसका एक बहुत ही बेसिक काम
था जो आप ऑलरेडी फैमिलियर है
इससे जिसके बारे में आपको पहले से पता है
अब थोड़े से इसके कुछ एक दो एडवांस फीचर्स
है जिनके बारे में आपको बताने वाला हूं
क्योंकि वो जानना इसलिए जरूरी है जब भी आप
स्क्रिप्टिंग यूज करते हैं उनका काम आपका
नॉर्मली जरूरत पड़ जाती है उन जो फीचर्स
की जरूरत आपको पड़ जाती है शिफ्टिंग के
अंदर और आपका काम और भी आसान हो जाता है
विद द हेल्प ऑट सबसे पहला काम क्या है जो
टिल जो कैरेक्टर है य जो टिल वाला जो
सिंबल है इसकी हेल्प से आप यह पता कर सकते
हो कि जो करंट सिस्टम है जो करंट मशीन में
है कि जो पर्टिकुलर यूजर वैलिड यूजर है या
नहीं दोबारा बता रहा हूं कि करंट मशीन
मेरी कौन सी है
और मैंने क्या लिखा नहीं एक को डॉलर नहीं
करा मैं एकको टिल दे सिंबल उसके बाद मैं
सिंपली कर रहा था अभी मैं लिख देता हूं
मैं लिखा मैंने अभी रूट यहां पे मैंने
लिखा रूट हिट एंटर अब इसने करंट यूजर्स की
होम डायरेक्टरी
को प्रिंट करने के बजाय इसने किसको प्रिंट
किया रूट यूजर्स की होम रूट यूजर्स की होम
डायरेक्टरी को
क्यों इससे एक तो यह कंफर्म होगी जो रूट
यूजर्स है वो इसमें एजिस्ट करता है
ओके तो अगर मुझे यहां पर नॉन एजिस्ट यूजर
फ एपल कोई भी मैं काम करता स्विच करता हूं
एक बार मैं अग
इसम बार को ड यूर कर ड यूजर मैंने लिखा स
ड यूजर कर दिया
ओके स ड यूजर एस ए सी सटर कर दिया
न्यू पासवर्ड
वाओ ओके डजन मेरा हो गया अब मैं क्या करता
हूं अगर मैं एकको करता हूं उसके बाद टिल
डेड सिंबल और मैंने लिखा
सचिन ट एंटर अभी स्ल होम स्ल च इसने आपकी
स्क्रीन के सामने प्रिंट कर दिया तो इससे
आपको कंफर्म हो गया कि ये जो सचिन नाम का
जो यूजर था यह सिस्टम के अंदर एजिस्ट करता
है अगर क्या होगा अगर मैं वो यूजर का नाम
लिखू जो इसमें एजिस्ट करता नहीं एक डॉलर
मैंने एक टिड सिंबल और मैंने लिखा
कुछ भी जैसे कि लिख दिया मैंने नितेश ए आई
टी ई एस एस नितेश कर दिया और इट एटर अभी
इसने एज इट इज इसको प्रिंट कर दिया इसके
अंदर क्या होता है कि अगर कोई भी यूजर
आपकी मशीन में एजिस्ट नहीं करता करंट मशीन
में अगर उस यूजर नेम के साथ अगर मैं टिल
सिंबल का यूज करता हूं आगे जैसे अभी यूज
किया तो उस केस में क्या करता है ये
एक्सपेंशन काम नहीं करता ओनली वैलिड यूजर
के केस में एक्सपेंशन काम करता है इनवैलिड
यूजर के केस में काम नहीं करता य आपके
सामने एक तो फीचर यह था यह काफी हेल्प कर
सकता है जब आप स्क्रिप्टिंग कर रहे होगे
दूसरा क्या होता है
कि आपका जो बेस्ट सेल है ना वो उसके पास
कुछ सेल वेरिएबल है जिसके अंदर क्या करता
है वो आपकी प्रेजेंट करंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री ये कुछ क्या है बैस
क्या करता है कि कुछ इंटरनली क्या करता है
इस करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टर की वैल्यू
स्टोर करके रखता है इसके अंदर फॉर
एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया सीडी किया स्ल
ईटीसी किया फट एंटर किया अगर मैं एकको
करता हूं और डॉलर करता हूं पीडब्ल्यूडी अब
इसने ईटीसी की वैल्यू को यहां पर प्रिंट
कर दिया अब बैस क्या करता है बेस के अंदर
एक और चीज है कि ये ट्रैक रखता है क्या
रखता है कि प्रीवियसली वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी
कौन सी थी
प्रीवियसली वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी कौन सी थी
और उसका भी ट्रैक एक सेल वेरिएबल के अंदर
स्टोर करके रखता है अब वो कौन सा है
एकको डॉलर ओल्ड
पीडब्ल्यूडी ये रहा ओल्ड कौन सी थी इससे
पहले में किसम था स्लश होम स्लश काली के
अंदर था जो आपको पता है उसके बाद मैंने
शिफ्ट किया था सीडी ईटीसी के अंदर और
पीडब्ल्यूडी क्या ईटीसी अभी कई ब आपके
सामने ऐसे सरकमस्टेंसस आएंगे जहां पर आपको
क्या है फ्रीक्वेंसी
एक वन डायरेक्ट टू अनर डायरेक्ट ऐसे ही
मूक आगे पीछे आगे पीछे अब ऐसे केस में यह
दोनों वेरिएबल काफी हेल्पफुल होते हैं अब
यहां पर प्रॉब्लम यह आती है कि बारबार
आपको इनकी फुल नाम को टाइप करना होगा
पीडब्लूडी ओल्ड पीडब्लूडी हो सकता है
बिगनर के साथ को गलती होगी या उसको समझ
में नहीं आया या उससे याद नहीं रहा टाइप
एरर भी हो सकती है सिटेक्स भी हो सकती है
तो थोड़ा सा टिपिकल पड़ जाता है तो अब
इसका एक फीचर्स है जो टिल डेट एक्सपेंशन
में प्रोवाइड किया गया इसका शॉर्टकट है
क्या शॉर्टकट है कि मैं आपको शो करता हूं
इसके
सामने कमेंट करके
कि जो अगर मैं टिल डे उसके बाद प्लस सिंबल
इसके साथ यूज करता हूं तो किसका शॉर्टकट
है यह शॉर्टकट
है शॉर्टकट
फॉर पीडब्ल्यूडी शॉर्टकट फॉर पीडब्लूडी य
पीडब्ल्यूडी का शॉर्टकट है अगर मैं ऐसा
करता हूं डेट माइनस सिंबल यूज करता इसके
साथ ये किसका शॉर्टकट है ये शॉर्टकट
आपका शॉर्टकट
फॉर ओल्ड पीडब्ल्यूडी ओल्ड पीडब्लूडी का
शॉर्टकट है ये इन सबके शॉर्टकट क्रिएट कर
ताकि क्या है कि बारबार आपको पीडब्ल्यूडी
ल्ड पीडब्ल्यूडी आपको मेंशन करना पड़े और
आपका काम बहुत ही आसानी से हो जाए इसको
मैं प्रैक्टिकली दिखाता हूं लेकिन उससे
पहले एक चीज आपको ध्यान में रखना है कि जो
पीडब्ल्यूडी की वैल्यू है या ओल्ड
पीडब्ल्यूडी दी है दोनों की वैल्यू
ऑटोमेटिक हर बार अपडेट होती है जब भी आप
किसी डायरेक्टरी के अंदर चेंज करते हैं
ऑटोमेटिक अपडेट हो जाएगी फॉर एग्जांपल अब
मुझे क्या किया मैंने किया सीडी किया मेरे
प्रीवियस वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी क्या थी तो
मैंने टिल डेड सिंबल यूज किया ओल्ड पीड
यूज करने की बता और मैंने माइनस सिंबल यूज
किया हिट एंटर कर दिया अब ऑटोमेटिक मैं
अगर मैं करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी देखूंगा
तो ओके एकको करता हूं उसके बाद ट स और
प्लस सिंबल ट एंडर अब क्या मेरी प्रेजेंट
वर्क डायरेक्ट कौन सी है पीडब्ल्यूडी स्ल
होम काली फिर से मैं बैक जाता हूं तो ये
रहा टलेट ये रहा वापस से मैं एटीसी के
अंदर आ गया फिर से मैंने क्या किया फिर से
होम के अंदर आ गया फिर से एटीसी के अंदर
फिर होम के अंदर अब प्रेजेंटली मैं किसके
अंदर ह होम के अंदर हूं फिर से मैं बैक
गया ये रहा उसके बाद मैंने प्लस करता हूं
ये रहा टीसी के अंदर तो इस तरीके से ये
शॉर्टकट काम करता है तो ये दो एडवांस
फीचर्स थे टिल डे एक्सपेंशन के और यहां पर
आपका टिल डे एक्सपेंशन भी खत्म हो गया अभी
तक हम हमने कितना कर लिया आज की क्लास में
इतना ही करेंगे आपको बता देता हूं कि
टॉपिक क्या चल रहा है टॉपिक हम चल रहे थे
इसमें कहां पर
था ये रहा टॉपिक चल रहा था स्टेप थ्री
एक्सपेंशन उसके अंदर हमने पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन हमारा क्लियर हो गया और ली
एक्सपेंशन क्लियर हो गया नेक्स्ट क्लास
में हम पढ़ेंगे कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन भी बचा है नेक्स्ट
ब्रेस पढ़ेंगे उसके बाद वर्ड पटिंग और
ग्लोबिंग ये बचा उसके बाद हम स्टेप फोर
में जाएंगे जो है आपका स्टेप
फोर आपका ये
रहा कोट मूल और उसके बाद स्टेप फाइव
डायरेक्शन में जाएंगे तो अभी आप लोगों के
लिए सिर्फ दो मिनट है किसी को कोई डाउट है
तो आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हो मैं आपके चट अभी
चैट लेने के लिए रेडी हूं आज का कांसेप्ट
इतना ही था नेक्स्ट क्लास में नेक्स्ट
टॉपिक के साथ हम पढ़ेंगे अभी तक जिसका
स्टिल कोई भी डाउट है रिलेटेड टू कांसेप्ट
वो मुझसे अभी पूछ सकता
है
स्टिल एनी वन है एनी डाउट मुझसे पूछ सकता
अभी तो ग्रुप में पूछ लीजिए कि बूटेबल में
आगे जो भी प्रॉब्लम आ रही है पूछ स क्या
प्रॉब्लम आ रही है स्क्रीनशॉट भेज के
ग्रुप में हमारी टीम से कोई ना कोई रता वो
भी आपको बता दे अरवा मैं भी बता दू कोई
नहीं आप ग्रुप में स्क्रीनशॉट भेजिए और
प्रॉब्लम लिखिए कि क्या प्रॉब्लम आ रही है
अगर ग्रुप नहीं पता तो आप टेलीग्राम का एक
ग्रुप है उसमें जाकर जवाइन कर सकते हो
यहां पर हमारे डिस्क्रिप्शन लिंक में मिल
जाएगा डिस्क्रिप्शन में लिंक मिल जाएंगे
सभी
के
ब
ओके फिर सेशन एंड करते हैं
तो बाय बाय थैंक यू सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन गुड डे